على بقى المستشار الالمانيه
للتاثير على روسيا
مع رئيس الوزراء الصينيه في بيجين قال انه
يتفق مع الرئيس الصيني على ان التهديدات
النوويه غير مقبوله
الوضع الراهن في تايوان
وبحث معه العلاقات
في العالم بما فيها الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
والتنميه العالميه
شيماء اهلا بك خلاص مصادر من المواقف بعد
هذه اللقاءات للمستشاره الالماني مع
الرئيس الصيني ورئيس الوزراء ايضا بخصوص
كل تلك الملفات
نعم تحيه طيبه مريم وعبد القادر المؤتمر
الصحفي الذي جمع كل من المستشار الالماني
او لاف تشيلسي في اول زياره له الى الصين
منذ توليه منصبه مع رئيس الوزراء السنيه
لكوتشي عام اثار خلاله عده ملفات على راسه
ملف تايوان اكد ان الحل او التغيير الوضع
الراهن لجزيره تايوان يجب ان يكون عبر
الحوار وعبر الحل السلمي اثر ايضا قضيه
الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا وتاثيره الكبيره
على امدادات الطاقه وايضا على سلاسل
الغذاء العالمي من جهته الرئيس سجين في
خلال لقائه به قبل المؤتمر الصحفي كان قد
اكد على ضروره عمل الجانب الصيني والجانب
الالماني باعتبارهما من الدول ذات النفوذ
الكبير في العالم على تعزيز السلام في
العالم وايضا دعم سلاسل وامدادات الغذاء
العالمي تحدث ايضا شولز عن اهميه التعاون
فيما يتعلق بملف التغير المناخي اثر ايضا
ملف الانسان في الصين لم يشر همم الاسم
الى ملف حقوق الانسان في اقليم شنجان
لكنها وقال بان ملف حقوق الانسان يجب
التعامل معه داخل الصين فيما يتعلق
بالاقليات العرقيه لكن يمكن القول مريم
بان زياره الشغل على راس الوفد من كبار
رجال الاعمال الالمان اليوم الواحد فقط
اليوم هي ذات طابعه اقتصادي او يغلب عليها
الطابعه الاقتصادي كون الصين تعد اول اول
او اكبر شريك تجاريا لالمانيا على مدى
السنوات الماضيه ايضا تشير الارقام الى ان
التعاون او التبادل التجاري بين برلين
وبيجين انما بنسبه 15% خلال عام 2020 وهو
ما يعادل قيمه 245 مليار يورو كل هذا انه
الكبير رغم الانكماش الذي شهده الاقتصاد
العالمي يؤكد على قوه وصلابه العلاقات
التجاريه بين البلدين وايضا اا قدرتها على
النمو رغم التغيرات الاقتصاديه التي شهدها
العالم عقبه جاء حتى كورونا هنالك ضغوط
كبيره اتشولد مثقلا بها سواء داخليا في
المانيا او خارجيا هو اول رئيس من مجموعه
السبع او اول قائد من مجموعه السبع ياتي
ويقابل الرئيس سجن وجها لوجه بعد تعزيز
سجن في مكانته في الحزب الشيوعي همم
الصيني وكنت هنالك ايضا همم كلام او حديث
عن شراء قصه كبيره من ميناء هامبورج في
المانيا ولا دي عارضه سته مسؤولين همم
المان وهو ما جعل شغل تحت ضغوط كبيره خلال
هذه الزياره شكرا جزيلا لك شيماء شوقي
ايمن